The earthquake and tsunami that occurred on March 11 caused the cooling system that triggered the nuclear accident at the Fukushima Daiichi Nuclear Power Station
to shut down, causing core melting in the three reactors.
The only thing the military and government could do was to inject water to
prevent further damage to the core, and even now that the crisis has passed,
Fukushima is still in a very dangerous situation.
Thousands of people are involved in situational investigation and convergence work, and
in some places high levels of radioactivity can be detected that can be fatal in minutes.
Workers always wear masks and protective clothing.  Must be worn
Here we are spraying anti-
diffusion agents for radioactive substances and water is also a big problem.
Also detected and pollution has spread far from the site.
Radiographs show that
radioactive material has
flowed to its northwestern part.
Thousands of locals were temporarily inhabited when the nuclear power plant broke out.  Some people have evacuated to a shelter
but will no longer be able to return home for decades to come.
TEPCO apologizes to the people for this child's voice,
but at this time the people at 3 o'clock
TEPCO and the government are the target of attacks
The recent resignation of former Prime Minister Naoto Suga was mainly due to the inadequate response to the nuclear accident,
but there are signs of improvement.
The other day, an elaborate filter system for purifying radioactively contaminated water was
installed, and the
same measures will be taken for Units 2 and 3, which have also installed the cover for the Unit 1 nuclear power plant building.
Aiming to maintain the cooling of a damaged nuclear reactor without injecting cooling water into the nuclear power
plant accident is a regional disaster, but its impact has spread throughout Japan in various ways.
The worst nuclear accident in the last 25 years has attracted worldwide attention, although power shortages have become a problem other than the occurrence of earthquakes that have relied on nuclear power as the source of
supply, but the increase in current power supply is
questionable.
The agency
iaea visited Japan to investigate the damage situation,
and some countries are reconsidering the position of nuclear power.
Germany has decided to completely eliminate nuclear power,
while the United States and China have conducted long-term safety assessments.  Are
Let's return to Fukushima The
long-term impact remains uncertain
. The Japanese government has promised to clean up at least some areas around the power plant, at least in Japan and around the world, where fuel needs to be recovered from atomicity
.
It is only certain that this accident and its consequences will follow for decades to come.